une nouvelle journée de grèves et de
manifestations le 20 février prochain
décision de l'intersyndicale hier soir
elle s'est réunie au terme d'une
nouvelle journée nationale de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites
1 121 mille personnes ont défilé dans
l'hexagone selon le ministère de
l'intérieur contre 108 mille la semaine
dernière l'unsa ratp appellent de son
côté un lundi noir dans le métro et le
rer dès le 17 février date qui
correspondra au premier jour de l'examen
en séance plénière du projet de réforme
par les députés le texte est
actuellement discutée en commission
spéciale et je vous propose d'écouter
ces manifestants hier quand le
gouvernement dit que les femmes seront
les plus grandes gagnantes c'est
absolument faux je veux dire c'est
mathématique
1 on sait que dans la fonction publique
on est quand on part en retraite c'est
sur les six derniers meilleure année
c'est les six derniers mois
aujourd'hui si on prend sur une carrière
complète de la faim qui va toucher au
minimum 45 ans on sait très bien que les
femmes qui ont des enfants avec des
arrêts les enfin les congés mater et ses
mains elles seront obligées de
travailler bien plus voilà que l'âge
prévu les enseignants étant pas
extraordinaire mais rondement bien payé
ils sont assez bien payé en fin de
carrière est en fin de carrière
on va la retraite est calculé sur les
six derniers mois
maintenant ça serait calculée sur les 25
dernières années
du coup il y aura une perte de retraite
d'environ 30%
bien sûr qu'on se ressent la baisse du
budget tous les secteurs par exemple les
dépenses de crédits pédagogiques ont été
divisées par dix neuf depuis
l'an 2000 et ce genre de démonstration
peut la faire dans tous les domaines
pour se bat pour un service public de
qualité qui va aussi avec le statut du
fonctionnaire et donc de fait qui est à
rapprocher de la question des retraites
de la sécurité sociale et
bon